les témoignages on les a des étudiants
qui se mettent fin à leurs jours dans
leurs résidences universitaires il y en
a mais je comprends pas en fait que la
réponse du gouvernement soit aussi
faible par rapport à une détresse qui
est aussi forte c'est la faculté avait
été ouverte
c'est il allait voir ses camarades on
aurait sans doute pu le détecter ou même
ses professeurs
[Musique]
une
le cora navires us est un est un facteur
très aggravant le job étudiant n'existe
quasiment plus nous sommes tous isolés
c'est quelque chose qui qui est tout
nouveau qui vient d'arriver
mais c'est quelque chose qui devient
terrible
[Musique]
déjà quand on a quand on a un cours de
un cours magistral 1h 2h 3h
même si on met cinq dix quinze minutes
de pause pour scinder le court en deux
la tension elle baisse forcément donc
déjà en présentiel c'est compliqué
les témoignages on les a des étudiants
qui se mettent fin à leurs jours dans
leurs résidences universitaires il y en
a mais je comprends pas en fait que la
réponse du gouvernement soit aussi
faible par rapport à une détresse qui
est aussi forte
[Musique]
ils ont l'impression d'être les oubliés
de la crise souvent inscrits dans des
établissements publics
ils se sentent ignorés noyés dans la
masse et livrés à eux mêmes la confusion
et l'absence de perspectives qui règne
en cette rentrée de janvier ont généré
et amplifier une angoisse est un mal
être chez nombre de jeunes qui nous
oblige à agir et prévenir la situation
des étudiants de notre pays ils paient
un lourd tribut à cette crise sanitaire
fin décembre je rencontre le président
lui bien facilité picardie on a fait
passer des questionnaires auprès de nos
étudiants il raconté sur les 3450
réponses qui nous surmonter 20% ont
scénarisé leur suicide ya un biais d'
enquête je me suis y est et puis vient
te tomber l'étude nationale elle de
santé publique france près de 30% 29%
exactement déduit 8 25 ans sont en
dépression 50% la moitié 1 sur 2 sont
inquiets pour leur santé mentale est
certain combien ne se contente pas de
scénariser leur sus il
[Musique]
il faut arrêter de dire que c'est la
situation sanitaire qui nous empêche de
mettre un pied à la fac parce que
dédoubler les classes c'est possible il
suffit de créer des postes de travaux
dirigés et je vous assure qu'il ya plein
de personnes qui attendent que ça en
fait de pouvoir justement avoir un
travail et une rémunération de chargé de
td
[Musique]
m